c'è una ragazza che si è messa lì a
cercare tutti e dico tutti gli insulti
che pietro si è beccato dal sottoscritto
nell'ultimo anno insomma io ho preso
questi insulti ottenuto i più belli
diciamo cevoli più significativi e ci ho
fatto una compilation una sua quanti
abbiano fatto la compilation del genere
su youtube ma io sì io posso buona
visione
ragazzi nel trapianto di cervello il
paziente in questione e pietro perché
chi altro poi fare un trapianto server
diamo un motivo a pietro di esistere
perché con quello che adesso che si
ritrovano nel torino guai a brutto
essere subiti 3 2 1 all è perfetto
pietro ti ho liberato lato del tuo più
grande peso
vediamo che cosa possiamo inserire
all'interno per rendere pietro più
intelligente di prima
ok storia adesso dovesse essere molto
meglio di prima dietro e tutto scemo
pagato nostra la cosa più bella del
gioco ma anche la più misteriosa pietro
a pietro muore meno male presenti il
ghetto entra dentro gravissimo se noi
stiamo ballando to valli non uccide due
balli dietro a tutti che nelle mani di
pietro pensate mica questa era una
giocata da pietro è di quelle pervenute
horror di estero ha chiesto per chi non
lo conoscesse ma state fuori dal mondo
se non lo conoscete questo genio quindi
non è pietro adesso abbiamo pensato a
persone che mi sono vicine che quindi
ivano che siano nella mia vita invece
adesso pensiamo a persone che mi stanno
sul cazzo pietro è diventato famoso
grazie di un bel sì vabbé va e chi stato
per la polizia amava puzza pure no anche
faremo fare che si fuma marijuana
sì però mettiamo noi da saad ricucci e
fa video con le cuffie cm non so però
diversamente
e per forza le stesse marito angelo per
diventare una chiusa no no no mi farà
con aguzza quello io no a chi stai
pensando a quel maniaco di pietro povero
nome americano e quindi a me piace dire
grande bob bellissimo sempre sognato
nella mia vita dire grande bob
ma me lo dire anche quando morirò qui
tutti i meriti del mondo e pietro a
tutti i the mary ma allora io ti devo
chiedere innanzitutto scusa bob prima
cosa chiedo scusa per pietro ma tutti i
giorni e allora mi dispiace
[Musica]
pietro
dimmi
sei accorto anche tu che c'è una bestia
qua gigante che somiglia un po a pietro
il nostro sale di statuto che ti fa male
eh lo so è un po come significa dei
servi e tradotto allora fratello ci sono
situazioni peggiori
ad esempio potresti fare un video in
collaborazione con pietro è morto è
morto perché non sopportava l'idea non
so esattamente noi ucciso mez così
traditore della patria schifoso pietro
no ma questo è così idiota dio mi ha il
profumo e la vittoria non sa di pietra
lo sa più di bob i propositi per questo
2018 tirare uno schiaffo a pietro più
forte chi manca il giappone e se sì cosa
maggiormente si mi manca stare lontano
da pietro ma anche 2006 123 a
ha veramente funzionato un tuo piano
come la pisciando qualcuno forse pietro
no è un tubo che percio l'unica roba più
brutta di questo gioco e giocarli coop
con pietro pietro famiglie è chiaro
iscritti
ovviamente bullismo guardavo di quella
volta che siete iscritti tra i due
allora smettiamo o coma pietro impalato
però cos'è sta roba
cos'è comunque uguale a pietro ragazzi
non usate il conto per cortesia usati
cono che sono poi i risultati sono
incasinati vedete pietro quello è morto
nella lavatrice pietro ammorbidente
modern and women del libro di pietro
questo ha aperto il sacco giorno
c'era un tizio lì dentro veramente
brutto
e non si tratta di pietro e pietro è
morto shalalala yo una vita è una vita
maledizione una vita una famiglia un
cane o pietro devo badare a pietro con
l'amore se non ci sono io muore perché
non sono anche mangiare se non lo invoco
la mattina e malanni schiocca le dita
pietro è morto o tutta la vita
eva pietro lapidato perché guarda che ho
anche se lo domanda va avanti serate
perché sono io che girava come la
ragioni la fisica di la pira venga ma
cosa venga non riescono a notare fin lì
credo mi hai voluto fare suicida mentre
questa vai vai spingi spingi spingi
ancora ecco che mi lasci juba ciao
pietro già pietro cambia no non sono
riuscito a lasciarti qua staccati rai
uno scafo schifosa aspetta insomma non
farlo sei proprio al volo per me che al
volo
tre punti al torino ma tu sei scemo mai
pietro più vera
sei lento come una scarpa morta abbiamo
un distacco di punti che è veramente di
poco però come possiamo vedere abbiamo
fatto lo stesso numero di gol
lo stesso numero di as lo stesso numero
di di parate di tiri beh prime e ai meno
pink di me e meno pigri me è in meno pil
bravissimo c'è io sono riuscito a
schiantarmi sono riuscito a schiantarmi
sul porco il pietro di soffitto questo è
rituale per battere il drago del land
dopo va bene ecco lo uccide il pulcino e
batteremo il drago ma io proprio con
questo elemento dovevo fare una serie di
minecraft certo scegliere sempre il
membro più una non è portare va persa
grazie
puoi essere più stupito
porca vacca e cacciato pietro quando ce
n'erano per le balle alla connessione
che funziona benissimo quando c'è da
fare le cose tipo questa crush un genio
mai buonanotte perché devi dormire
vicino a me ma vai via maledizione vai
via schifo
ammazzatelo ammazzato così vi amo pensa
che prima se non avevamo la spada quella
che hai tu adesso ma perché questa
persona e b è nata tra miliardo di
spermatozoi hai vinto tu porca vacca
guarda c'è una pecora nera lì e poi c'è
anche questo animale grazioso allora qua
si fa il salto della fede pietro 6 prima
tu però vado vado se funziona vieni se
tu stai andando a fuoco io avessi
dell'acqua io la berrei fra ci sono dei
pony ma che figata
cosa ci fai qua dentro pietro cosa ci
fai qua vedi pietro questa è la quantità
di ragazze che ti cercano ai ha chiamato
ma c'è uno zombie qua sei scemo ma tu
sei tu che drogato ciao amico ci vediamo
una maledizione c'è la barca non posso
spacca sporcata da qualche modo con
l'idea non la mente
no no no la scritta no ai a ma avrai dei
ritardi ma tu ci hai dei problemi
vediamo si abbaia fermi fermi no no no
ha dei problemi questo cane un po come
te ecco questo qua sembra più un dito
medio te lo dedico a colpo sicuro
bravissimo grazie grazie madonna
colpo di culo mal di pancia ma poverino
il brodino questa sera e mi sa di sì ho
sentito rompere le palle per lutto
e se umano robot di stampo chiara o mal
di pancia posso avere mal di pancia è
una volta nella vita mi fa troppo mal di
pancia se cosa faccio devo fare per
farla passare mal di pancia che cosa
faccio per cagare guardo i video di
pietro e queste ragazze era la
compilation insulti venti ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto spero che
voi trattiate i vostri amici meglio di
come i trattori ora si sente in viaggio
e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo insulta
pietro ragazzi
[Musica]